vacations are really interesting because
for many families it's one of the
biggest discretionary expenses
throughout the year right of course we
pay more money on housing and so on but
vacations are discretionary and the
question is are people getting the most
happiness that they can out of their
vacation dollars and and a couple of
interesting mistakes that people make
when it comes to vacation think about
the time line you have the time before
the vacation you have the time during
the vacation and you have the time after
the vacation before the vacation is the
time that you get to think about the
vacation and anticipate it during the
vacation is when you actually enjoy the
vacation and afterward it's a time that
you savor you look back you think about
it and so on from those three periods
which is the shortest the actual
vacation right in fact when you think
about the vacation you don't need you
shouldn't think just about the vacation
you should also think about anticipation
and also think about memory and I can
tell you that there personally we've
gone to some vacations with my family
that at the moment were not fantastic at
the moment you would say it was that we
climbed some mountains it was difficult
it was complex and so on so the actual
vacation itself every moment of it was
not exactly joyful but reflecting on it
backward has been just amazing so that's
one thing about the vacation is you
really want to think about the whole
experience and what vacations are going
to actually enrich your life and become
input for memory for years to come and
not just something that is good for its
own sake another interesting thing that
come back but vacations over and over is
whether to repeat the same vacation
we've been to before or whether to try a
new spot and repeating something we've
done before has some advantages it's
kind of a sure thing you know what to
expect there's not going to be
disappointments but are they going to be
a unexpected excitements probably not as
not as well the famous economist
sitarski
had this wonderful book called the
joyless economy and he said there are
two things in life they are and
pleasures income
the things are really amazing and I
think that's that kind of okay and what
happened is that too often we don't do
the amazing things because we go for the
okay things so what happened is you say
to yourself oh I've been to that beach
before it was perfectly fine I don't
want to risk it let's do it let's do
this again and it's true you're not
taking any risk but are you really
building the kind of amazing repertoire
that would feed you throughout the year
and make you happy about that vacation
probably not as well so I think
vacations need to be something that is
beyond the specific vacation and we need
to be very worried about doing the
comfort rather than the real pleasure